[Music]
there are thousands of refugees entering
Bangladesh every day they cross the
border of Myanmar where the state
military has launched a violent
offensive against an ethnic minority
group the rehén juh the UN reported that
since August 2017 about 400,000 rojan
Djem men women and children have fled
their homes in Myanmar's Rakhine State
reports claimed that the military has
been killing and raping the RO Hanja and
has set their villages on fire
satellite imagery showing burned
villages confirms those reports because
Myanmar has refused access to human
rights investigators the current
situation cannot yet be fully assessed
but the situation remains or seems a
textbook textbook example of ethnic
cleansing the term ethnic cleansing has
been reserved for some of the worst
atrocities in history the UN defines it
as a purposeful policy designed by one
ethnic or religious group to remove by
violent and terror inspiring means the
civilian population of another ethnic or
religious group from certain geographic
areas
what makes Myanmar a textbook example is
that the military has been launching
attacks on the RO hanja a Muslim
minority in a majority Buddhist country
violent tactics have forced tens of
thousands of RO Hinda to flee their
homes while many fled to Malaysia and
Thailand most ended up in Bangladesh the
recent wave of violence is the latest in
a pattern of discrimination that started
over 50 years ago in 1962 Myanmar then
called Burma was taken over by the
military in a coup they got rid of the
country's constitution and created a
military Hunta like many dictatorships
they promoted fierce nationalism based
on the country's Buddhist identity and
when they needed a common enemy to help
unite the population the rehén de were
singled out as a threat tensions between
the Burmese Buddhist population and the
RO Hanja go back to the Second World War
when each group supported opposing sides
the rehén de sided with the British
colonialists who ruled the country and
the Buddhists mostly sided with the
Japanese invaders hoping they'd help end
the British rule after the war but even
in modern Myanmar the rear-engine
minority continued to be an easy target
although their lineage can be traced
back to 15th century Burma
the government has been forcing them out
claiming their illegal immigrants from
Bangladesh
it started in 1978 after a massive
crackdown called Operation Dragon King
forced about two hundred thousand row
honja to flee to Bangladesh the military
reportedly used violence and rape to
drive them out about a hundred and
seventy thousand Roe Hansa reportedly
returned to Burma then in 1982 the
government passed the Citizenship Act
recognising 135 ethnic groups the ROE
henjo with a population of about 1
million were not on the list and became
a stateless people in 1991 Myanmar's
military launched another campaign
literally called Operation clean and
beautiful nation this time about 250,000
rojan jet fled to Bangladesh tensions
continued to build against the row hinge
in the 2000s violence broke out in 2012
when four Muslim men were accused of
raping and killing a buddhist woman in
recline buddhist nationalist backed by
security forces attacked Muslim
neighborhoods burned homes displacing
tens of thousands of Rohan juh again
Human Rights Watch deemed it an ethnic
cleansing campaign by this point the
Rohan juh were persecuted
disenfranchised and stateless in 2016 a
row hinge a militant group that are a
Conroe hinge a Salvation Army emerged
and coordinated small-scale attacks on
border police stations an attack on
August 25th 2017 left 12 police officers
dead and sparked the current crisis
against bro hinges civilians a brutal
retaliation by the state security forces
has led to about 400 deaths and the mass
exodus of about 400,000 Rohan juh to
Bangladesh since the August attack 210
villages have been burned to the ground
the violent campaign has triggered the
fastest growing humanitarian crisis in
recent years but Myanmar's de facto
leader and Nobel Peace Prize winner Jung
sang-soo Chi has barely acknowledged the
attacks
more than 50% of the villages of Muslims
are intact they are as they were before
the attacks took place when she says
that you know 50% of the Muslim villages
are still present in Rakhine State well
I mean what are we talking about 50% are
gone
50% are burnt out you know in any school
I went to 50% as a failing grade recent
reports claimed that the military has
planted landmines along the Bangladesh
border to prevent the rojan jaw from
returning
Myanmar's government has systematically
driven the revenge' out of the country
over the last five decades it has
stripped their citizenship terrorized
them and destroyed their homes and now
it wants to keep them from ever coming
back
[Music]